okay
i think we'll get started and people
will trickle in as uh as they will
um i'm ani adikari i teach statistics at
berkeley and i thank you so much for
coming here there are many many options
for you to choose from i'm very
delighted you're here that's when some
of you i know have flights to catch very
soon
um
the reason i am standing up here
i'll try to make clear by
explaining
my connection with moocs at berkeley we
have a
an introductory statistics course called
statistics two there is no statistics
one i don't know why
um it is a semester-long 15-week course
and it is
it satisfies
uh what is called berkeley's breadth
requirement it satisfies the
quantitative reasoning requirement for
graduation
uh it is taken not only by people who
are you know wanting a quantitative
course for graduation but a lot by
pre-med people
it is a course with very little
mathematics
so it is a statistics course with almost
no mathematics and uh the prerequisite
we say is high school algebra
and that is a code for i will not write
a summation sign on the blackboard right
i try to avoid x as much as possible
because one of the things we are trying
to do is to not get lost
in algebra or not to use the algebra as
a shield
uh and to rather to get to you know ex
talking about what the
ideas actually mean
so that's stat two and uh i decided that
i would
turn that into a mooc and a little bit
more of my motivation i'll talk about in
a minute
so uh stat two got transformed into
stat2x on edx
and because i was imagining this student
motivating himself or herself through a
statistics course
you know
in some location far away i thought that
would be a very difficult thing to do
for 15 weeks
and so i broke it into three five-week
segments
so and the material naturally breaks
in that way and there's a couple of
weeks gap between each at the end of
every five weeks if they complete they
get a certificate and i think it really
keeps people going because there is a
very short tunnel
and you can see the light at the end of
it the minute you enter
so we did three five-week segments and i
was quite honest about the prerequisite
i simply called it arithmetic
and specifically arithmetic meant
if you understand that 1 over 2 is the
same as 0.5 is the same as 50
you are in if you understand that
one-third is not the same as 30
you are ahead of the game
right so that's the class and i had a
specific reason for this uh level of
prerequisite uh partly because it is
sort of commensurate with what we do in
uh in stat two and i wanted to
adhere to the principles of uc berkeley
x with which i agree which is that we
should teach the berkeley course not
somehow watered down for a general
audience
but the berkeley course so just to be
consistent with that and for other
reasons which i'll talk about in a
minute that was the prereq
and so
here they are
these three courses you can find them on
edx those are the three logos uh five
weeks of descriptive statistics five
weeks of probability theory and then
another five weeks of putting the two
together into statistical inference the
basic stats uh
from starting with nothing
to ending up with being able to
i hope read the summary of a statistical
analysis
in a paper
and that ran twice
in spring 2013 and spring 2014
and let me tell you a little bit about
what happened
so first i'll tell you why
i did it and
the practical reason is i did it because
armando fox who was sitting here
about half an hour ago uh came up to me
and said hey how about a mooc we've got
uh edx going and you know we he was
director of berkeley x at the time and
i didn't think too hard and that is the
principal reason that i did it
and i thought for five more minutes i
probably wouldn't be here
um
but
what was
inside what was making me do it
primarily three things
and the first was
this lies damn lies and statistics
you've all heard it
and you don't hear la it's attributed to
mark twain he may or may not have said
it anyway everybody else says it
you don't hear lies damn lies and
physics
you don't hear lies damn lies and even
economics
but you hear lies damn lies and
statistics and why do you hear that it
is because people read stuff
and they sort of don't understand and
that makes them very resentful and
suspicious
they read stuff that is just flat out
wrong
and they know that it's wrong and
therefore they know it's lies
and it's numerical
and they attribute that to the subject
but what's happening of course is that
the subject is being used and is being
read by people who have no idea what
they're reading
and so here was my chance
to do
for the world what i do routinely in
stat 2 in berkeley
following the footsteps of other faculty
in my department david friedman in
particular
to demystify
to lift the fog from statistics and
statistics labors under a thick fog
um and is
one of the more poorly taught subjects
in the world
and so this was my chance
and i grabbed it
and just to give you a sense without
taking up too much time of
how i teach
my
i feel that in any statistical analysis
there are three parts
there's a scientific problem there's the
question
and that generates the assumptions under
which you are allowed to work
that's part one
part two is once you've decided what
you're gonna do there's the calculation
and then part three is
understanding what the numbers mean that
you have calculated the interpretation
of the mathematics of the arithmetic
that you've done
and the typical statistics course will
focus
on part two
on the calculation
here compute this
this is a standard deviation compute
this right perform a t-test
well great but a machine can do that you
don't actually need a human intelligence
right you can just go into r and type t
test and it will pop a number
what you need our brains for is parts
one and three
and so my class focuses on one and three
and i make part two as easy as possible
and uh
that
is
uh something that was uh that i learned
from uh david friedman in particular
there are very few people who can
genuinely claim to have
transformed the way a subject is taught
david freeman of berkeley could
legitimately have done that
his statistics textbook written with
roger pervis and robert pizzani came out
in the 1970s it's simply called
statistics and it is perhaps one of the
greatest introductory textbooks in any
subject anywhere
um so there was that
demystifying it
and second is
i think you can guess that i
come from india
and i remember very clearly
being among
large groups of very bright young people
frustrated
because the materials at our hands were
so paltry
and the teaching was you know people
were doing their best but you know it
was kind of much of it was kind of
routine and we just had this sense that
if only somebody would talk to us
that we could fly
and this was
a way for me to give back uh it was an
opportunity for me to participate
in giving
uh anybody in the world
a high quality learning experience for
free
um
and so that meant something to me and i
did that and when and you know i say to
students everywhere and really it's it
is almost everywhere there are by most
counts about 196 countries in the world
you know
give or take a few countries where some
people can't decide whether they're a
country or not but roughly roughly
195 or so among my students
are represented 186 of those countries
right that is really a worldwide reach
um and that was a privilege so i took
that
and the third is there's numerical
information everywhere everywhere you
keep hearing big data well little data
is all around you and has been forever
and it is very very important i think
for people to be able to make sense of
data
and so um
i wanted to
develop students who would look at
numerical information in an intelligent
manner
who would be able to read a statement in
the newspaper that said researchers at
the university of california at berkeley
have developed have discovered a highly
significant link between this and that
and have some sense of what that means
and know what questions to ask what is
missing in that article
what
might have gone wrong what is probably a
take away from that article to read that
intelligently
to be able to understand why
uh
opinion polls can be based on point one
percent of a population and still be
accurate
that kind of thing the the standard
numerical stuff that you see everywhere
i wanted people to have some real a
solid sense of what is behind that that
is my main motivation for teaching stat
2 and
stats 2x
and so i did it that way
by the way
this format that i'm using this blue and
gold this is exactly what my students
see
in my mooc
i was very conscious of the perils of
distraction so you heard this morning
don't distract your students
so i
don't have my face
showing on the screen there is
at the start of a section i appear
and i talk for a bit but this is what
they see
um
and
by focusing my mind on the student's
experience i
i deliberately didn't have myself
videoed doing my lectures
because that's not the student's
experience the student is not in a room
with 300 people listening to a lecture
the student is by himself or herself in
their own room possibly at one o'clock
in the morning with headphones on
and so it is a one-to-one
conversation between me and the students
so i forced myself to recognize that
this is me
not in lecture
so i did not throw my voice which is
what i do in lecture
but i spoke
to my microphone
as though it was a student sitting
across the desk from me
and that method has worked very very
well the student somehow felt that there
was a connection
even though they didn't have uh the the
face
and so as a result of all of this and
i'm sure with some good luck
it went down well
um
i would say anywhere between 70 000 at a
conservative estimate to 90 000 people
and it's two runs
completion rates i mean if you're going
to measure success by completion rates
which you've heard
here and i agree with is not the right
measure to use
were high i mean the typical completion
rate five to seven percent for one of
these large moocs and we were doing
anywhere between 10 to 17 percent
um
i don't like that measure so i won't hop
on it but students liked it and
there was a lot of demand for the next
course
and that's all fine um
it was just a wonderful wonderful
experience
but you know no good deed goes
unpunished and so there was a
consequence and the consequence was
armando fox walking into my office again
about this time last year
and saying
we'd like to run it three times a year
and i froze and this talk is
born out of my sheer cold terror at
hearing those words
because you know there's a good thing
the students like it and he wants to do
it again and again and again because we
feel that we can teach the course by
pushing a button
right it's right there go again
and i
being the person who actually did it had
a sort of freakout moment and i realized
very clearly that i did not want to do
it again and again i suddenly wanted to
do it twice you want to fix the goof ups
the first time and i may after a gap
want to do it again but i do not want to
do it continuously
i didn't sign up for that nobody would
want to do it continuously
and so
how would i help edx keep its program
going because they want to run the class
and so we get into what were the
obstacles for me teaching it again
and the first one
was i've got a paid job
i'm employed full-time by the university
of california
and you know they're not paying me to do
this
this was over and above and there's only
so much you can do over and above and
that was one of the questions raised
just about an hour earlier in the same
room i think by you right it's an
important question
right how do we keep sustaining this
enterprise
um and universities need to make up
their minds about what their mission is
i think it's an important mission at
least at the introductory level to get
good introductory materials out there
for the world
if nothing else it helps teachers
um it gives teachers a
resource
that was not easily available before it
gives teachers a resource all over the
world i think we have a responsibility
but that is you know at the moment still
a subject of some discussion i have a
job
even if i didn't have that job
i do have other things i want to do
right there's i mean the world is not
limited to stat two there are many other
wonderful things that i want to do and
even if i had
no other job and no other interest i
firmly believe in the following
the world does not need to keep hearing
from me
right it is very important to have a
multiplicity of plurality of voices
and so i'm sitting there thinking okay
so then
what how do we make this work and i had
to think about okay so what actually is
involved in me teaching this course
that's how i started what's involved in
me teaching this course again
and so
there is basic course admin that we have
to do anytime we teach a course there's
some you know you set up what's the
schedule when are the tests when etc etc
and that's sort of laid out in the
package that is already developed but
you know it was laid out for spring 2014
and you're teaching it in fall 2016 you
have to do a little date adjustment you
have to decide whether you want the
quizzes to count for 40 or 30 all of
that kind of thing that you have to do
fine that everybody has to do that
um and that's the nitty-gritty
um
what does it mean to actually teach
and if moocs have done anything
they have really shown a spotlight on an
inequality that we have been hearing
over and over again at this conference
and that's this one
teaching is not equal to delivering
course materials
and so the delivery of the course
materials in some sense was already done
and so then what did teaching mean
well teaching to me no matter what even
when i'm standing up in front of 300
students in a class it is not me it
teaching doesn't flow this way
teaching flows both ways teaching's a
partnership it's a collaboration between
the students and me
and the course is not something i offer
i don't use that verb
offering a course because it feels like
it's going this way
but it's something that the students and
i uh create together so i tell my
students you're not in my class to
listen to a lecture you're here to roll
up your sleeves and work with me
um and so
the teaching
is what happens when the students and
the teacher can hear each other
and so when does that happen in a mooc
well at some level it happens during the
exercises you ask them to do something
they do it it comes back and edx sends
them back a green check mark or a red
cross
now that is communication of a sort you
really hope that communication doesn't
end there
and what's really bad about that
communication that really lacking in
that communication is you know what
happens when a student comes to you in
office hours and they've done something
and it's not quite working out and
you're talking to them and you tell them
no no but think about this what do they
do they say no but but i thought it was
going to be like this
and what that green check mark and red
cross do though they give feedback is
they don't give the student the
opportunity to go but but
they don't give the student the
opportunity to argue
they have to argue with you
and so when does that happen
it happens in one place in an edx course
and it happens in the discussion forum
and the critical back and forth i hear
the students in the discussion forum
and so leading that discussion forum i
believe is the key to what i call
reteaching a mooc
i'm not developing the materials but i'm
teaching the mooc communicating with the
students hearing them
that's the
job
well so if i look at that if that is the
job of teaching
and delivering course materials this
thing up here
is a different thing and has already
been done
that means these two things don't have
to be done by the same person
and so then very clearly you've got
another partnership going you've got the
person who developed the course
materials and you've got the person who
actually does the teaching they don't
have to be the same person
at the moment the way edx is set up the
instructor of the course
the name of the instructor is
the person who developed the course
there are other instructors perhaps but
that person is always called the
instructor the person who developed the
course i don't want to be ever in any
course just a nominal instructor i don't
want to be a name
so what i would like is to be called the
author of the course
and so what i'm suggesting is that we
take a look at something that we
understand quite well familiar ground in
a traditional course you've got an
instructor who does of course the course
admin and then works with the students
and in two places in the lectures and
outside the lectures we're also used to
having an author of a course textbook
that's a different person that's the
person students never see
that's person in the background
somewhere they've provided course
materials in mathematics classes that
text usually contains a set of exercises
what i'm saying is let's take a look at
the mooc
and in the mooc what happens is this
traditional course instructor gets split
into two people
there's a person who handles the course
administration and does the real
teaching with the students outside of
lectures
and then there's the person who delivers
the course material
and in our minds the instructor has been
so inextricably linked to lectures that
i think it's time to separate that
so what i'm saying is we split the
traditional instructor into possibly two
people could be the same person but into
possibly two people and then you have
the third person the author of the
textbook
who is still there
and the author of the course in a mooc
is much more present than the author of
the textbook because the author of the
course
is either visible in the video lectures
or at least audible in the video
lectures they're much more human than
the author of a textbook is so these two
people
are
people that the students meet
but it's this person the instructor with
whom the students can speak
and if we just use this model then i
think it allows a person like me to
create a mooc teach it a couple of times
and they just walk away from it and have
armando and anand and other people
use those materials with possibly
somebody else teaching
as many times as they want as many times
as they can get people to teach
the class
in just the same way
as
you would
write a textbook
and then people all over the world use
it
and so it doesn't limit edx
and it doesn't tie a millstone around my
neck forever and so i would hope very
much that all of the
platforms would consider this model
and
what i'd like to look at now is does it
matter who teaches it
and so now my mooc has been put in
quotes because you know i did a part of
it but the actual teaching i hope will
be done uh by somebody else so does it
matter well
who does it matter to edx i hope not
much
right if students register for the
course and if the instructor does a fine
job it should not matter to edx that
it's me or somebody else
um
edx should speak for themselves here but
i really feel that that is a reasonable
expectation
does it matter to me
well as far as i'm concerned uh creating
the course is off the order of having
written a textbook
right having created some course
materials if i had written a traditional
textbook
then hopefully if it's any good i would
not be the only person in the world who
only who used it
it would be used at universities all
over the place i would not even know who
is using it
right that would be some uh
budi would adopt it
and so as far as i'm concerned it's very
similar to that i don't i don't feel
tied to my mooc
does it matter to the students
i don't know
uh my guess is
again if the instructor is doing a good
job it should not matter to the students
after all
resnick and hilda wrote a great physics
physics textbook decades ago it's being
used now are the students distraught
because it's not resnick and holiday
teaching them
i hope not
because there's significant problems
with redneck and holiday are not around
to teach them anymore
no they love the book so i don't think
it will matter to students but will
their reactions differ depending on
whether it's the author of the course
or
an instructor at a different university
from the person who is the author of the
course or a graduate student
well
if it's being done well i think not but
i think not is not a good enough answer
so what we're doing currently is we are
attempting to run a randomized control
experiment
run the course
split the forum
and have the different bits of the forum
run by different types of people in
different ways
and see if there's any effect on student
learning and
it's an ongoing experiment i had hoped
to have the second round of the course
just ended a month ago
i had hoped to have some data for you
but
what happened was that we discovered
that the experiment was not so easy to
do
and
because it's a little digression from
the main points that i want to make
i will not discuss right now
what the issues are with the experiment
other than to say that it's been a rocky
road but we're smoothing it out
once we are uh
done with this
if you have questions that are
interested i will be very happy to
discuss what happened with the
experiment and what we are trying what
we are trying to fix
in the end i do have
you know
susan singer yesterday had so many gems
in her keynote that it is actually very
hard to focus on one part of a talk and
let anything else go one of the things
she said was qualitative analyses are as
important as quantitative analyses and i
have a very clear qualitative sense from
the students
that it will not matter to them that it
is not matter much to them that it is
not the author of the talk uh not the
author of the course who is
doing uh
their
the communication as long as they learn
um
so
whether or not it matters to the
students i think it will not matter much
uh mattering to edx what does it mean
for the instructor to do a good job and
i would like to like to focus on this
because teaching tens of thousands of
students well does have a few things
that you have to take care of
um and so this is my view on what it
means to do a good job teaching at least
my mooc
and so the first is and this people will
look at this and go well it's course
administration
clarity consistency policies schedules
expectations
course engineering that is consistent
with your policies and
expectations and you know this is a
no-brainer
however
it's not easy to do those of us who have
taught classes in person classes with
hundreds of students know that it is not
easy to do it is not easy to maintain
over a period of 15 weeks
and the more students you have
every time you make a goof up that is
administrative
the more dramas you cause
the more anxiety there is and with the
mooc
unlike your face-to-face course where
students are registered and they need
that for credit
with the mooc
they signed up for it because they
signed up for it they will drop out
and so making the course run smoothly
acquires an importance
even beyond the importance that it has
uh
in face-to-face classes this simple
little thing don't annoy the students
because of logistical nonsense
it becomes very very important so that
is an important part of running a course
well and you know i'm sorry to belabor
what seems like
an obvious point
and then it's the instructor's job to
welcome students in
at the beginning the day the course
starts the instructor i feel needs to be
present
and say hello bring them in and to
explain to them
the importance of their communicating in
the forum and one of the things i tell
them is they're on campus my students
see me they see me at coffee shops they
see me wandering around when i walk into
lecture i will say oh could you believe
the traffic on earth avenue you know
they see me as a human being
whereas in
the mooc
they see me talking about statistics and
yes i have picked lively examples and
yes i have a sense of humor and so on
but you know they're still kind of
removed from me as the human being and
so i tell them that it is difficult for
me to teach unless i'm seeing human
beings it is very difficult to teach the
generic absent invisible student and so
to make my job easier and to make you
know
me do a better job for them would they
please join in the forum and once you do
that and once they start coming in
they encourage each other but that
initial
availability is quite important and with
a mooc like statistics 2
186 countries
age group ranging i believe from 11
to over 70.
middle school students retired people
neurosurgeons radiotherapists
psychologists mathematicians
people wanting to learn machine learning
and people just wondering what on earth
this subject is about
and the big group of people who hated
every minute of it when they took it
right they hated it
but you know they really need it for
something and they're going to give it
one last try
that is a big and varied group
and being able to talk to them
all of them and make all of them feel
included that is a difficult task and
that is a primary thing that you need to
do
a good job and you have to do it in
writing
you got to do it in written english to
people who have no english
this is not trivial
and one of the things that
always trips me up is humor
because i have the slightly you know
laid back style and every now and then
i'll crack a joke and people say this
that i say off the wall things that make
them wake up fine but off the wall
can be uh humor is very culture
dependent
and so off the wall can be pretty
difficult and one of my problems to do
with picking chocolates out of a box
there's dark chocolates and white
chocolates and uh
milk chocolates and you know picking at
random and then what's the chance that
the 12th person who picks has a dark
chocolate and people write in because i
have forced them to think about the
assumptions they write in saying okay
is it with replacement or without
replacement so i shoot back
it's chocolates
of course it's without replacement i'm
eating them
and
the discussion forum goes haywire wait
who's eating the chocolates chocolate it
doesn't say it's been eaten
what's being eaten did you eat the
oh my i shouldn't have said that i
should not have said that
but you know you do want to be able to
have a lighthearted conversation
with a
globe full of people it's a difficult
thing to do
and i will say you've got to handle the
flames
you have to set the tone
and you have to lead
so please imagine the student in their
own room
sitting and sending you essentially
email
and know what happens to perfectly nice
people
when they send email when they're upset
they turn into godzilla
yeah they're sitting by them it's like
when they are in a car right there is no
inhibition there is no community around
them and they just fire something off
and it is the instructor's job to come
in very calmly
and deal with it know when not to engage
but also to
you know enforce
the same kind of communication that they
would be in your office so this is a
difficult thing but all of these
need to be done
i am not the only person in the world
who can do this lots of people can do
this they don't have to be at berkeley
and so i would hope that there's a large
number of people who are possible
instructors for my course
what does it matter to me i said it's
comparable to writing a textbook and
here i just want to be very clear about
what it means and i want to point to
something that was asked about now an
hour and a half ago here
comparable to writing a textbook so
here's my author's bill of rights
i'm not a rebel
i'm not doing anything dramatic here i'm
just saying some things that i think are
obvious
first
i want to have my own copy
and i don't
i
somewhere i'm sure i can extract my
course it's not given to me as a normal
thing i think it just ought to be i
ought to have a soft copy of the entire
thing because if edx decides to pull the
plug maybe i can do something with it i
wrote it so i ought to be able to do
something with it this is obvious
and this i think is just purely
easily easily taken care of
the second
i want the integrity of my work
preserved
if you look at a book
people can use it
in classes they can use any portion of
it they can use other books to
supplement it
they can make nasty comments about the
book
they're all free to do all that but what
they can't do
is get inside the book and write other
things in between your paragraphs
they can't get inside the book and
delete portions of the book the book
exists as an object
i would like the course materials to
exist as an object
and
others not able to modify it without my
permission i might be fine with them
modifying it but i would like to have
the option to say no and let me say why
i am saying this
i am extremely extremely conscious as a
teacher of elementary statistics
that
what kathy castelli was referring to the
other day that if you have lots of
materials out there the cream will rise
to the top the community will select the
best materials
i sat there and i sighed because my
reaction to that was oh i wish
the cream in statistics has not risen to
the top there is a
multitude
of awful textbooks out there
that are used continuously because
people insist on looking at that compute
this because it's easy it's much harder
to talk about assumptions it's much
harder to talk about interpretation
and it has become a thing
and i really want the course to maintain
that integrity
of focusing on the science
both of the assumptions and of the
interpretations
and essentially not doing rubbish
in another course i might have a
completely different attitude if i do
the next course which i think is the
calculus based probability course that i
would love to be able to do
i would be very happy to have people
join in and
insert things of their own there's a lot
of wonderful stuff out there
so what i'm saying is i would like to
have the option to say yes or no to
somebody being able to modify the course
and i think this is you know
no derivative works it's a standard kind
of license
uh instructors of course are free to use
any portion of it they are free to
assign uh other texts as they wish but i
want this to be clear and from edx
in edx there is you know when you edit
uh problems and solutions at the moment
the way it's set up
if you when you edit the date of a
problem the date when it's due
which you have to edit because you're
running it some other year
the same screen allows you to edit the
content of the problem and so we tell
the faculty member you may not edit the
content
but of course you have to edit the date
uh that's a software issue i would like
that edit button to just disappear from
the content
and that will be very reassuring to me
um
i'm acknowledged as the author of the
course this i'm sure there will be no
problem
so instead of instructor i would love to
be called the author
and here is a killer
i own the copyright there is this has
been said very nicely by berkeley x and
people at edx
saying you know the faculty member owns
the copyright it is not a given by any
means
textbooks there has been a long-standing
agreement between universities and
faculty that faculty who write textbooks
even though they've done it on
university time somehow it's their
textbook
online materials not so clear
and what i would like is clarity and i
think this discussion has to be had
otherwise faculty will not continue to
produce materials and that's one of the
things you were referring to who owns it
right this discussion must be had
and i will uh what i find wonderful is
that people have come in edx at least
has come into it with a very uh
it's a perspective that makes me want to
continue producing materials armando
here one of the first things he told me
it's your course uh he was director of
uh berkeley x at the time uh anant
agarwal all of those people but
you know they are not the only people
involved there are layers
there is edx there is berkeley x
there is mit harvard there is uc
berkeley
and everybody has lawyers
um and so all of those that that that
does need to be clarified that's a very
serious thing
and my final
uh thing in my bill of rights is that
money is getting involved
licensing syndication all of that is
getting involved
if money gets involved what i'm asking
for is a clarity of an agreement between
the parties involved
myself
and my department
and then edx and berkeley x all of those
flat those entities that helped put this
course online i'm not saying what the
agreement should be i'm not saying it
should all be mine i'm just saying there
should be one
to which we all agree
those are my four things that i want and
i think i hope you will agree that
that's not
rebellious
right i i'm not making big waves here
i'm just saying clarity
now is this new i don't think so
it is again familiar ground
we've done this with textbooks
and i believe we know how to do it
we just
have to do it
it's not been done yet
so i'm encouraging a conversation on
this and i would love to see this get
done because this is a way
of
keeping the
mooc project going encouraging faculty
to keep producing materials reassuring
them
and
really making it uh feasible
sustainable
so uh here's an email address shoot me
an email uh if you have uh discussions
but i hope that a lot of the discussion
will happen now so i have a couple of
things that i would like to address we
could just throw it open to questions
but i'm quite interested in two things
i'm quite interested in your views
on
what you would think about your mooc
would you be okay with other people
teaching it and if so under what
conditions that is one thing that i
would love to have a discussion on and
the other is
what do you think authors rights should
be or instructors rights i mean
how do you think we should come together
this is after all an open environment so
what is involved now i'm going to say
that this is being webcast and so we'll
do the usual thing of questions into
microphones shibani there is going
around the room with the microphones and
so i see a question there and we'll
start with you yes
thank you so much that was wonderful um
i can share an anecdote from penn state
um we have a
we've done two moocs that my department
did uh so what department is that oh
sorry um i am a director of an institute
in earth and mineral science okay the
college of earth and mineral sciences so
we did one on mapping
using gis software and we did one on
energy and the environment
um that's the one that i think is a
close anecdote to share it was authored
by a nobel prize winning professor
he is a character he is so wonderful
entertaining but we knew in in
convincing him to do this mooc that he
would never have time to
be a as involved as an instructor as
we'd like
so we kind of set it up this way from
the beginning
and what we did was hired a
high school
geosciences teacher
who had graduated from one of our
graduate programs
in geosciences to be his his course
assistant it wasn't a ta
he was he was a partner and he was the
one from the very beginning the first
day the course was ever run that was the
front line of defense so to speak in all
the discussion forums he was the one
doing all the things you so nicely laid
out um he did have
the backing of this nobel prize winner
if there were things he ran into he
didn't you know he could he could call
upon him
and richard alley is this this nobel
prize winner and and richard um
he ended up being more involved than he
had originally thought he would because
he got so interested and so passionate
but it went super super well and i think
the thing that was so interesting that
gets your question of do the students
care or do they even notice
when i read through the the remarks on
the message you know on the discussion
forums uh during the class and at the
end when we did a survey of students to
find out what they
thought of this mooc experience
they commented
uh so favorably about both
the course assistant and richard as if
they both had actively been involved in
the course because having watched the
videos
with richard jumping up and down and you
know acting certain things out and so
forth they felt like he was there
even though it was the other guy they
were actually interacting with on the
discussion forum so to them
they were both present even though
really richard was not if that makes
sense yes no exactly that's why you know
the the instructor the traditional
instructor splits into two people and
those are very important people there's
a question there one two and three so
okay
is it my turn
yes is this gentleman up here oh thank
you
and then you and then the person the
gentleman at the back yes
i i agree completely that
you should be able to have your own copy
of the course yeah and
in some
workflows that happens automatically so
when i i taught a street fighting
mathematics on edx and that was all oh
that was you yeah oh good loved it oh
thanks
all right that was all done through uh
latex to
the entire
workflow was latex files and figure
files written in asymptote and then
compiled with a make file right and then
it was all uploaded terrific
when i did stat2x latex to edx didn't
work well ah so we had people entering
things by hand into studio not a good
scene but i agree latex to edx would be
perfect because that that would solve
that first problem absolutely completely
then you know then i wouldn't need a
copy i would have mine you'd have it you
could run it i couldn't agree more a
nice way of uploading would be terrific
yeah so i'm very glad that latex to edx
works thank you for that
um
just to address that really quickly if
you're using studio i can show you how
to export your course
it'll export the whole thing no i know i
know it does i just i just meant that it
should happen as a normal time sure sure
right yeah um so just to give you a
qualitative analysis of the few things
you talked about about do the students
care so i i was that second instructor i
took over a non's class after he did 600
2x and and um and
my qualitative analysis is yeah the
students don't care that it's not the
author in the forum talking with them
but i did still have the mit phd behind
me and so and i think that did matter
because when i was giving encouragement
in the forum it was a big deal that this
mit person was giving them feedback and
giving them praise and encouragement um
so i do think that is a big deal um the
other thing i want to talk about was uh
you mentioned about not changing the
materials so one of the things like by
the time i taught the clydesdale for two
terms by the time i was doing it for the
second term i had students who had taken
the class four or five times so the
material okay it's just for me to
understand why
why were they taking the class four or
five times because now they were in the
forum assisting the students who needed
help
i and i i was able to anoint them as
community tas they had their own label
and it was key because that's how i
could teach thousands of students and
not be answering all their questions and
i could be focused on encouraging them
to do other things and to do outside
projects
but so it was kind of key for me to be
able to update the materials because
those students who were taking it for
the fourth or fifth time wanted to see
new things so all of the exams were
always new
and i also tried to update the at least
one problem per problem set every week
so um i i don't know if that fits into
your model of not editing the material
what do you think of that so as far as
far as i'm concerned
uh
as long as
the set of materials that was originally
provided is kept as an entity
any additions
uh can be done by the instructor
it's just
the
i i would like to have the option to
decide whether or not the person can
actually
uh insert things
and delete things
in in in
in a given course and so you know maybe
maybe
what you do is you know what what i have
is in blue and what you have is in
purple and it's very large type and it's
very obviously different maybe
but
especially if the course is going to be
used in many different places with many
different instructors
i
i would ask that it'd be done sort of a
little bit separately
so you can have for example
mit has a probability theory course
where uh in an exercise set every
problem appears on its own page
terrific
you add your own pages
no you just don't offer mine
okay so that is deleted right so that's
right
that enables you to approve deleting
your idea yeah they can use any subset
of the materials
yeah i just don't want things inside no
no they don't have to do everything that
i said you have to do right you can
assign problems to a and two b and not
to c
um as far as i'm
it's not it's not deleting it's choosing
not to use
right when i have a textbook
right then
the students can read the entire
textbook and i will assign problems 6 8
and 14.
the other problems remain
so that's what i'm saying so what i'm
saying is
it doesn't go away it's there exams
exams are private anyway
right so exams exams are quite different
exams cannot be seen by the student
anywhere until the moment the exam is
supposed to appear
so it doesn't appear that's fine
the next person who gets the course gets
the course in the form in which it was
originally written
so thanks for drawing out the author
versus instructor distinction i think
it's very healthy um i i'm a mooc
instructor i have a course on coursera
and i'm very proud of the structural
integrity of it right from beginning to
end i know where everything is and why
every i was dotted and t was crossed and
it i would never claim it's perfect but
it is it is you know my body of work
what subject uh programming languages in
computer science
let me just offer maybe a couple
friendly amendments in in a couple
directions so first of all it's not
necessary to divide everything up it's
incredibly healthy and to figure that
out but i think for many of us and
probably yourself as well one of the
things we love about being professors is
that on any given wednesday we do 17
different things that need not be done
by the same person it is it is part of
the fun
uh and and that's okay and it's
important to recognize these
distinctions as as we do
and then people have noticed in the mooc
space that of course you can divide
things more finely and and different
people will want to do things slightly
differently i imagine there will be some
course authors that don't want to do the
course management and the deadline
setting and all that but would actually
really enjoy on a 10 minutes of day
pretty much for forever as long as it's
not mandatory participating in the
forums it's their facebook it's their
email it's something that they derive
great personal satisfaction from doing
and hopefully not in a way that gets in
the way of what you're calling the
course instructor
and then on the authorship side you know
i i have faculty i helped
organize a different mooc on campus
where one person did the videos and a
different person did the homeworks and
it was a wonderful collaboration and
they you know and and they both
you know it wasn't quite co-authoring
because it was pretty different set of
stuff but maybe we would just call that
co-authoring um and you know there's
going to be a hundred variations of i
think the very high level distinction
that you've laid out here and and i
think that's healthy
i don't think you're proposing uh a
model a distinction you know the author
does this and the instructor does that i
i have author and instructor singular
but if you look at any edx course
typically there is more than one
instructor
right and there may be more than one
author
i just had it to stop cluttering up my
screen with esses
but
you can certainly have more than one
person authoring a course and more than
one person being the instructor i think
the person who does
the administration and so on
is an instructor just like anybody else
that can be called an assistant you can
have very many different what i wanted
the the point that i'm trying to make
is that when i am not actually teaching
the course
i don't want to be called the instructor
that is the point that i'm trying to
make
right so one of the things you know
we've seen uh copies of draft licensing
agreements and so on and there's a lot
of emphasis on using
the name of the person who created the
materials and i say great use it
but call them what they are
don't call them something that's nominal
if i can say that about a name
uh more
thank you for the talk that was
excellent uh i have a couple of quick
questions and your billa writes you
right have your own copy
given
the
position of some universities that the
course is likely to be owned by the
university and you own the content do
you
think you might want to amend that to
say to have use of your own copy that
you can use it any way you want or you
just
care to have a copy as opposed to if you
move from berkeley you may not be able
to use it elsewhere quite i mean i would
love to have use of my own copy and so i
think those four are actually linked
right if you
uh
once you have agreements about one of
them that that will affect the other
you're quite right
having use of the own copy would be a
good thing to do i'm not sure that we're
going to be able to manage it
not every university is going to agree
um so that's an important distinction
thank you for making it and and this the
other part that was not in your bill of
rights is the
i i saw that you have if money comes
into play but that's really after
the course gets marketed and sold but
there is no
request from you to get paid for the
work up front
which if you think about a university
like ours putting together a course
everybody else is getting paid for the
work the production work etc except for
the instructor
uh in many cases but you didn't state
that that would be one of those no you
know i didn't state that because i had
in my mind so this is this is you know
my
uh what i would want and i think i can
see how people would want that
uh the thing is i've been in a
department where so many of us have
written textbooks
right so many of us have written
textbooks and you don't get paid for
that
that is something you do sort of off to
the side and you know one of the things
we're doing so we refine that textbook
uh through teaching uh courses that use
those materials
and so
i am actually
okay with developing a course sort of on
my own time it's been done a lot
that said
there have been
grants gates foundation and so on that
buy out teaching time so that would be
good to have
i would like to say that i am not
insisting on being paid for developing
the course
um
that is something that is for me
something that i do as part of my
profession in the same way that i could
not insist on being paid for writing a
textbook
but there's an i think there's a
response back there
i mean it's a very healthy
conversation to try to come up with a
bill of rights because if you will
because i think the bill of rights is in
some sense a super set of what any one
of us might find really really important
i i'm with you i developed my mooc for
zero dollars and zero cents i did it for
the love of the game i like to say and
and so be it but unlike you uh i'm less
wed
to
the the
single object structural integrity on
the mooc platform whatever platform i'd
be on i'm adamant about that but when a
colleague at another university says i'm
thinking of using and adapting
some of your materials i say here they
are do whatever you want with them now i
don't think i think you should have a
right not to do that but personally i'm
okay doing that so you know if if other
people feel that the compensation angle
uh is very very important to them even
though it's not important to you or to
me i think that's a really important
conversation for
authors to have
absolutely otherwise we'll stop getting
new materials right if people if if it
is not possible for people to develop
them just for uh you know various
constraints then uh the enterprise will
suffer so yes you're right that it is a
super set
and my my object today is not to
write a list of demands but to raise
issues that have to be addressed i think
for this thing to be sustainable and so
what i love is this conversation
this matters to me this doesn't matter
to me and for me you know the integrity
of the materials as i said i would have
a very different attitude depending on
which course i'm teaching i'm just
hyper-sensitive about introductory
statistics and the reason for being
sensitive is
there's a light shining on it
in the comments that are made by
students
so tens of thousands of students
hundreds of comments
and the thread running through the
comments and anybody who's been in my
course will attest to this
i never understood this till now
i took it as an undergrad i took it as a
grad student i'm using it in my
profession i never understood it till
now well why didn't they understand it
till now because they did have a lot of
people teach them there's a reason for
it
and so for that that one subject very
subject-specific i am very sensitive
other subjects i would be much more free
more
yes please can i pick up on the use
question
um
do you want the freedom to be able to
put your course on coursera or put it
onto facebook or youtube that's a very
interesting thing uh do i want the
freedom to be able to put my course onto
coursera or youtube uh at the moment i
haven't thought about it and at the
moment no
basically what's happening i think is
that the university or edx somebody is
becoming my publisher
right and so
more or less i'm going to have a
relation with them which was similar to
a relation that i would have with the
textbook publisher so if i published a
book with wiley for example right then i
couldn't go ahead and publish it with
chapman hall or whatever it is
and so there would be that agreement all
i'm saying is that i want that agreement
right and i want to be able to should
uh
edx decide that they're going to pull
the plug
then that agreement is null and void and
then i would love to be able to do
something with it if i want to
so i'm not saying that i want to be able
to use it under all platforms at all
times
so i'm not sure i answered your question
no that's good so there are two things
that come from that some of many of the
uh the courses they're cr their
materials are creative commons so
presumably you should be able to to do
whatever um but
the the second part of
viewing the courses the platforms like
publishers um
there are lots of hands in that pie so
you absolutely you would need to
so now we're talking about copyright
agreements rather than here is a course
that i produced for the love of it and
it's creative commons and anyone can use
it but actually i don't have use of it i
can't
my hands are tired i can only have this
on edx as long as yeah but see the the
issue there is
i don't actually have a platform right
so i have course materials somebody has
got to put it up there for students to
be able to use somebody's got to
maintain those servers make sure that
the grading software works and so on so
that that entity is quite important
and so my agreement will be with that
entity whatever that is so i can't
actually say i would like to use
i would like to be able to offer the
course what i can okay i'm done here my
computer tells me
i can
i can see myself offering the materials
to another platform
but i can't see myself saying here
i have a course because i sort of don't
i have
a whole folder of files
it's not something you can do anything
with
so i'm not sure i've got to your
question exactly but armando might have
a point of view he did have a hand up
um
they both work just to give a very quick
institutional perspective since i i got
embroiled at you know levels far above
my pay grade on uh some of these issues
berkeley has a very unusual
very faculty-centric very faculty
favoring governance model and because of
that unusual model the factual answer to
ani's question is she actually does
technically have the right to do
whatever she wants with her course
materials
berkeley can for all practical purposes
we cannot stop her if she chose to
put her course on coursera to put it on
facebook to put it up at one of these
various sites that we're now getting
emails from saying we will monetize your
course
uh so what we try to do is create
a culture and a set of circumstances
that makes it clear that that's not the
winning path it's not the best thing for
the institution and then in the long run
we believe it wouldn't be the best thing
for the instructor
but i can sympathize with my colleagues
and counterparts at other institutions
that have quite different policies about
who owns the intellectual property
inherent in the materials that faculty
members create
and if i were one of those people this
is one of the things i'd really want to
get out in front of
you know as i said at berkeley the
decision has been made this is
historically this is how it's always
been
my ip as a course author
is exclusively mine and the university
essentially has no control over it which
is an unusually
faculty favoring point of view
um and you know there are times when it
works for us there are times when you
could argue it works against us but if
you're in this room and and you are
dealing with this at your university get
out in front of this
because there are people who are going
to be approaching your instructors
directly and offering them money to do
things with their intellectual property
and this is going to come up if it
hasn't already
maybe a question that would help me
understand why you say that did you do
the course all on your own uh or did the
university invest
ten thousand twenty thousand fifty
thousand to do your course or was mostly
just
uh uh yourself there was a uh we had a
small gates foundation grant it bought
me out of one class and it paid for some
um uh engineering support
okay but then very very very small and
then and then after that
i think the the issue that i'm i think
there's not one answer they're going to
be situations like the one you described
but there are issue situations where the
university does make a a claim on some
of the work that's been done and it'll
be very hard for you to take that the
work that the university has created and
move it elsewhere without absolutely i
agree and i have a lot of respect for
the support that i've got from the
university and from edx i should point
out that it's 235 and those who want to
leave can leave without embarrassment
but i'm happy to keep the conversation
going for another second okay just to
clarify um although uh ani is correct in
terms of their support that she got but
i can tell you that even if she had
gotten full university support to do
this course it would not change the
answer of the question the university
could and probably will have conditions
such as
we get the right to essentially we we
become a licensee
you will license your course to us so
that we can do various things to it but
none of that would inhibit ani's ability
to also do whatever she wanted with it
and at berkeley because of the way the
governance model works that would be
true even if the university had funded a
hundred percent of the development cost
of the course but we're unusual yeah
that is a very unusual status
not in general
all right old thank you so much i'm
around
thank you for coming and sitting through
an hour i would be very very happy to
talk to you and thank you for all of
those who participated most helpful for
me for the next round thank you